Nos dicen que: "Adán voló su dron a control remoto
desde una plataforma. La función f modela la
altura del dron sobre el suelo (en metros), como
una función del tiempo (en segundos), después del
despegue". Lo que quieren que hagamos es trazar
el punto en la gráfica de f que corresponde a cada
una de las siguientes cosas. Pausa el video
y trata de resolverlo. Obviamente no puedes
dibujar en tu pantalla, esto es de un ejercicio de
Khan Academy; pero puedes visualizarlo e incluso
señalar con tu dedo la parte de la gráfica de f
que representa cada una de estas cosas. Muy bien,
entonces lo primero que tenemos aquí es la
altura de la plataforma. El dron está a la
altura de la plataforma cuando despega, porque
dice que Adán voló su dron a control remoto
desde una plataforma, entonces ¿cuál es el
momento en el que el dron despega? Bueno,
ese será el tiempo en el que t = 0 justo aquí.
¿Y cuál es la altura del dron en ese momento? Es
de 60 metros, de modo que esa debe ser la altura
de la plataforma, así que ese punto que tenemos
aquí nos dice la altura de la plataforma, y si nos
preguntaran ¿cuál es la altura de la plataforma?,
sería igual a 60 metros. El siguiente punto
es la altura máxima que alcanza el dron, así
que a medida que pasa el tiempo podemos ver que el
dron comienza a volar a una altura más y más alta,
hasta llegar a los 80 metros y luego comienza a
bajar, entonces parece que son 80 metros. Cuando
el tiempo es igual a 10 segundos, el dron alcanza
una altura máxima de 80 metros. Por último,
pero no menos importante, el tiempo en el que el
dron aterrizó en el suelo. Ahora podemos suponer
que el suelo corresponde a una altura del dron de
0 metros, y podemos ver que eso sucede justo aquí,
sucede cuando el tiempo t = 30 segundos, lo
acabamos de marcar. Y sé lo que algunos de
ustedes están pensando: hay otro momento donde
la altura del dron es 0, y eso es justo aquí,
eso está en -10 segundos. ¿No podríamos decir
que también es un momento en el que el dron
está en el suelo? Y es un punto importante a
tener en cuenta, porque si realmente estamos
intentando modelar el comportamiento del dron
desde que el tiempo t = 0, que es cuando despega
y durante todo el camino hasta que aterriza,
entonces probablemente queramos restringir el
dominio de esta parábola a valores de tiempo t
positivos. De modo que esta región negativa de
tiempo que tenemos aquí en realidad no tiene
mucho sentido, probablemente sólo deberíamos
considerar los valores positivos del tiempo
cuando estamos tratando de pensar en estas cosas.